e aí ela questiona tudo com você que fez
a galera quer falar uma coisa para você
e eu tenho imagens fortes pra mostrar
pra vocês
imagens fortes ué ele comprovam que
michael jackson está vivo de michael
jackson está vivo e ele está aqui em
sobral no ceará não sei que ele vai
fazer e eu não sei se ele está em busca
de clima quente não sei que muitos de
vocês vão dizer que a montagem muitos
vão dizer que é photoshop muitos vão
dizer que eu fiz no pent mas realmente é
um fato verdadeiro quero muito muito
mostrar pra você e eu quero pedir que
vocês compartilhem a todos os fãs de
michael porque michael está vivo michael
vive mas eu vou contar pra vocês depois
dos comerciais sapato social que farão
você bombar na sua festa de 15 anos e
dois meses sapato social sapato escuro
no couro para o homem atual corre corre
que só tem um pé pois a galera então
agora vou mostrar as imagens de michael
jackson eram dois amigos meus estavam
vindo de um feriado e por acaso eles
encontraram michael jackson na rua
mostrar a vocês agora a semana santa
sendo massa mas achou capaz obra é massa
de mais um é dois aquele que aquilo ia
michael michael michael michael michael
ii mandou michael
ai ai eu sei que são imagens fortes dos
fãs de michael a gente quer fãs gente
fica muito emocionada e vem mais por
jacques em nossos corações e aqui na
nossa frente então queria pedir para
você que estava decidido agora por favor
clique em compartilhar compartilha esse
vídeo mostra esse vídeo ao mundo que
michael jackson vivo e ele está entre
não compartilhe com quem você puder
manter os seus amigos baixo esse vídeo
onde no atlanta onde lado a tratar no
seu facebook clique em compartilhar
marca os seus amigos mostra que michael
jackson não vê que gostei você clicando
gostei você vai ajudar muito se inscreva
no canal para ver os vídeos se inscreva
no canal para ver nosso vizinho obrigado
michael d